مرحباً بالجميع ، اسمي يوسف فرج ،
واليوم أريد أن أبدأ معكم جميعًا
في رحلة لاكتشاف الذات والاستبطان ،
لذا
دعني أبدأ بإخباركم قليلاً عن وضع
قصة طفولتي
غريبًا
في الواقع ،
لكنني لم أتغير أبدًا حتى يحدث
شيء ما في الداخل.  لقد غيرت شيئًا
لم يأتي مع تقدمي في العمر فحسب ، بل مع
تغيير في التفكير ، وإعادة هيكلة للطريقة التي
تعاملت بها مع حياتي وكل ما
واجهته
الآن ، هذه الكلمات العظيمة رائعة
حقًا ، لكن لشرح ما سمح لي
بتحقيق ذلك.  يجب أن أبدأ من
البداية المفهوم الأول ،
الفكرة الأولى التي أدركت أنها
سمحت لي بتحقيق
الشخص أو تحقيق ما أردت أن
أكون
أجنبيًا ،
لذا أولاً وقبل كل شيء أريد تقديم
مفهوم الوعي ، هناك
نوعان من الوعي
الخارجي  والوعي الداخلي
وهما مختلفان تمامًا ، فإن
الوعي الخارجي هو ببساطة
القدرة على إدراك محيطك وإدراكه ، إنه
نفس نوع
الوعي الذي يسمح للغزال
بإدراك أن هناك خطًا هناك ،
لذا يجب أن أتجنبه على الأرجح لذا لا أفعل  لا
تؤكل أو نفس النوع من
الوعي الذي يسمح لقطتك أو
كلبك بالتعرف عليك كمالك له ، ومن
ثم هناك نوع آخر من
الوعي يسمى
الوعي الداخلي وهو القدرة على
إدراك وإدراك
هويتك الخاصة.
حقيقة أنك على قيد الحياة
ولا يوجد أي حيوان أو كائن حي آخر في
العالم لديه هذا غيرنا نحن البشر ،
ولكن في الواقع عندما نولد لأول مرة
كأطفال حديثي الولادة ، لا يكون لدينا سوى وعي خارجي
يمكننا فقط أن نتفاعل مع البيئة
المحيطة
بنا.  لا تفعل أي شيء آخر بخلاف
ذلك حتى يكبروا قليلاً ، لذا فهم
يتفاعلون حقًا مع والديهم فقط
ويبكون عندما يكونون حزينين ويبتسمون عندما
يكونون سعداء ،
ثم في سن الرابعة
يحدث شيء مثير للاهتمام
كل شيء  فجأة يكتسبون
وعيًا داخليًا ويعرفون من هم
ويدركون أنهم بشر
يمكنهم التعرف على أنفسهم في
المرآة أنهم فرد
ثم في وقت لاحق
في الحياة بعد ذلك بقليل في
حوالي سن  13 يكتسبون
شيئًا آخر بعيدًا عن
الوعي الداخلي ، هناك طبقة أعمق من شيء
يسمى الوعي الذاتي
والوعي الذاتي يختلف في
الوعي الداخلي لأنه لا يقتصر
فقط على إدراك وجودك بل
إدراك هويتك
هويتك ثقافتك قيمك
الأشياء التي تجعلك ما أنت عليه
كشخص ومن خلال تسميتها التعرف عليها والتعرف
عليها ، يتم وصفك بأنك
واعٍ بذاتك ،
على سبيل المثال ، دعنا نقول أنني شخص
لا يحب البروكلي أه
فكرة مدركة لذاتها ستكون أنني  ما عليك سوى
معرفة ذلك ، ولكن بعد ذلك يوجد
شيء آخر فوق ذلك يسمى ما وراء
المعرفة
وهو آخر شيء هو الكرز الموجود
أعلى قمة الجبل الجليدي الذي سمح
لي بأن أصبح ما أنا عليه ولكن الكلمة
نفسها هي في الواقع بورتمان أيضًا
للكلمة اليونانية  الفوقية التي تتجاوز
أو تعني ما وراء أو تجاوز
والإدراك وهو مرادف
للتفكير ، لذا فإنه يترجم حرفيًا إلى
ما وراء التفكير ولكنه يعني أكثر من ذلك
التفكير في تفكيرك
بالتفكير في ردود أفعالك تجاه
البيئة من حولك والتفكير في
أفكارك الخاصة.
دعنا نستخدم مثال القرنبيط ، دعنا
نقول إنني شخص ما وأعرف هذا أنني
لا أحب البروكلي ولكن
إذا كنت شخصًا لديه
ما وراء المعرفة ، فستتمكن من إدراك
ذلك على سبيل المثال ، لا أحب البروكلي
لأنه عندما كنت طفلاً  أجبرتني والدتي
على تناولها ، وعلى هذا النحو ، بعد أن
كبرت ، لم أعد أحبها بعد الآن ، لذا فقد
تمكنت بالفعل الآن من أن تسأل
نفسك أنك
أصبحت استبطانيًا وأدركت
السبب الجذري لـ  سلوكك الحالي
الآن لتوضيح ذلك فعليًا لإظهار
كيف يعمل في حياتنا الواقعية ، دعنا نلقي
نظرة على مثال ونلقي نظرة على هذا ، ضع في
اعتبارك أنه يستغرق بضع ثوانٍ ،
والآن
هناك مساران رئيسيان ربما يكون عقلك قد
اتخذه مع هذا  هنا ربما تكون قد
حاولت حل المعادلة أو
ربما يكون عقلك قد قدم
إجابة أم لا ،
وإذا كنت قد قمت بحلها ، فهناك عدة
طرق مختلفة يمكنك حلها ، كان من
الممكن حلها بصريًا
يمكنك حلها  على أصابعك أو
على الأرجح
فعلت ذلك تلقائيًا ، حتى أنك لم
تفكر في الأمر ، لقد رأيته للتو
وأعطاك عقلك الإجابة
وبالنسبة لمن لم يفعل ذلك ربما
لم تتم مطالبتك بحلها أو حل
عقلك  لم يره كشيء
يجب حله الآن بغض النظر عن
رد فعلك عليه ، من المهم أن
تفهم أن عقلك ربما يكون قد
اتخذ اختصارًا في هذه الحالة
وبالنسبة لأولئك منكم الذين قاموا بحلها تلقائيًا ، يبدو
الأمر كما لو أنك لم تفعل ذلك أبدًا
حتى أنك انتبهت إلى حقيقة أنك
كنت تحل معادلة ، فقد
أنتجت الإجابة للتو وهي مثيرة للاهتمام
لأنه في حياتك اليومية ،
يتخذ دماغك العديد من القرارات التي تتخذ
الكثير من الاختصارات التي تخرجك
من المواقف السيئة للمساعدة في الحفاظ على
تتحرك الأشياء لإبقاء يوم التدفق
يخرجك من المواقف الصعبة ،
لكن هذه الاختصارات الذهنية للغاية هي
التي يأخذ عقلك الآلاف من
الاختصارات والأزقة الخلفية التي
يخلقها عقلك والتي يجب عليك
التركيز عليها لأنها في كثير من الأحيان  ينتهي الأمر بأن
تصبح أطرافًا سطحية سطحية
تطفو على السطح وتنمو إلى مشاكل أكبر
لاحقًا في حياتك
وهذا هو بالضبط السبب الذي يجعلك تركز
عليها تدرك أنها تفهمها وتكون على دراية بها
وتفكر فيها
الآن لتوضيح ذلك حقًا
أريد أن  انظر إلى شيء أكثر
موضوعية قليلاً ، لذا هذه المرة تستغرق وقتًا
أطول قليلاً ، اسمح لنفسك بأن
تنغمس في ما تراه ،
لذلك مرة أخرى
ربما كان هناك مساران كان من الممكن أن
تسلكهما ، كان
من الممكن أن تجدهما يعني أن عقلك
قد قبله  الحافز المقدم
أمامها ووجدت معنى
في هذه اللوحة أو رفضتها
لم تجد أي مادة فيها ومرة
أخرى بغض النظر عن الطريقة التي فعلتها ،
ربما وجد بعضكم معنى من خلال
محاولة إجبارها على ذلك.  مكان
قد لا يكون موجودًا أو قد يكون موجودًا ، ربما يكون بعضكم قد
اقترب منه بشكل سلبي أكثر مما يسمح
لك بالتحدث إليك لكشف
أسراره وأي شيء قد يظهر في
ذهنك عندما رأيته
ومن ثم ربما لم يعثر عليه البعض منكم
مما يعني أنه ربما لا
يتفاعل عقلك مع هذا النوع من الأشياء بشكل
جيد
الآن هذه الأمثلة بينما
أعتقد أن مجرد تجريدي يوضح النوع الدقيق من
التفكير الذي تحتاج إلى القيام به عندما
تريد حقًا أن تصبح ما وراء المعرفي
إنه هذا النوع الدقيق من التفكير هذا
النوع الدقيق  من التساؤل عن الذات
يسأل نفسك باستمرار لماذا فرض
عقلي المعنى في هذه
اللوحة لماذا
لا يبدو أن سمة الشخصية هذه تختفي أبدًا أو لماذا
أقول هذه الأشياء حقًا عندما لا
أقصدها حقًا
كل هؤلاء الحكماء  عليك حقًا
أن تسأل نفسك حتى تتمكن فعليًا من
اكتساب نظرة ثاقبة على الشخص الذي أنت
عليه والأسباب التي تجعلك
الشخص الذي أنت عليه
الآن لهذا السبب ربما سمعت
شيئًا من والديك ومن
الوالدين في الجمهور ربما  عندما
كنت أصغر سنًا ، ربما تكون قد سمعت
شيئًا ما يتماشى مع
سنوات المراهقة
لأنه صحيح بحلول نهاية
سنوات المراهقة هذه ، ينتهي بك الأمر إلى امتلاك
آلة شيء ما مع كل إدخال
يعطي دائمًا مخرجات متوقعة ، لذلك إذا
كنت  شخص ما وُضِع في
سيناريو مؤلم عاطفيًا ،
قد تكتم عواطفك بوعي أو لاوعي
أو
تنفجر أمام الجميع ولا توجد
آلية أفضل من الأخرى ، إنها
ببساطة طرق مختصرة للدماغ
لإخراجك مما أنت  لقد تم وضع
ذلك في نموذجي عندما كنت طفلاً
ومن الواضح أنني لم أكن أعرف هذا في
الوقت الذي أدركت فيه أن
الطريقة الوحيدة اللاشعورية للحصول على ما أريده هي البكاء
والصراخ وجعل نفسي أبدو أكبر
وأقوى من  لقد كنت حقًا
وهذا ينطبق على العديد من الأشياء في
حياتك اليومية ، لذا يمكن حل وفهم العديد من المشكلات التي
قد تواجهك
مشكلات فريدة حصرية لأنفسكم فقط
من خلال
هذا ما وراء المعرفة من خلال السؤال
وبمجرد أن تدرك ذلك بمجرد
توصل إلى إجابة تسأل عن المسار
وراء هذه الإجابة للوصول في النهاية إلى
السبب الجذري الذي قد يكون سببًا لها
وفقط من خلال الإدراك الفعلي لهذه
الأسباب الجذرية وتحليلها ، يمكنك أن
تفهم حقًا سبب تحولك إلى هذه
الطريقة في المقام الأول ، يمكنك أن
تفهم حقًا  لماذا تكون سلوكياتك على ما هي عليه وفقط
من خلال طرح هذه
الأسئلة على نفسك ، يمكنك أن تعرف حقًا ما
لديك القدرة على تغييره فقط من خلال
طرح هذه الأسئلة على نفسك ، يمكنك
حقًا أن تكون التغيير الذي تريده
وعندها فقط يمكنك أن تصبح  الشخص
الذي لطالما بحثت عنه
وأصبح الشخص الذي تريده
وهذه هي قوة ما وراء المعرفة ، شكرًا
لك
[تصفيق]